is the the 12th of june 2020. and before
we start i'd just like to go through
a few matters um starting off with um
sort of a skype meeting etiquette to
minimize background noise and ensure
everyone can be heard can i ask everyone
to mute their microphones when they're
not speaking
can everybody introduce themselves
before they speak
just to make sure that we can identify
every person when they're having their
say
can you address other participants by
name as this will keep the conversation
flowing
and everyone can be heard please speak
loudly
and clearly to ensure everyone can hear
you
you're asked not to interrupt others and
please let others finish speaking
um before you offer any thoughts of your
own
there is an instant message facility
we ask that uh the use of this um
is kept at very minimum and only used if
for some reason you need to
get the attention of myself or or or the
chairman
otherwise we ask that you don't use that
that facility
please give the meeting your full
attention obviously activities such as
typing
may sort of uh just create distracted
noises
and finally on this matter anyone who
persistently interrupts or is disrupting
the medium will be asked
to leave or may be removed from the
meeting
this meeting is being broadcast live on
youtube
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the entirety of the meeting will
be filled except for confidential or
exempt items
if you're attending the meeting you will
be deemed to have consented to being
filmed
and that the images and sound recordings
could be used for webcasting
or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
so as i said welcome everybody this is a
an application this subcommittee is
being held to hear an application
for the grant of a new premise license
uh for premises at shotley vineyard um
at
shotley and
the applicant is
i've lost the name of the applicant mr
and mrs mills
yes mr bill that's under the company
name isn't it um
gold quest gold crest that's right thank
you very much
um the first or the second item
uh before i go to the second item i'll
just advise the procedure that we'll be
following it'll be in accordance with
regulations 15 and 16 at the the
hearings regulations of 2005.
and and briefly it will follow as
follows the
uh after after introductions the
licensing officer will uh provide a
quick report detailing
the application before the subcommittee
today
the applicant will then have an
opportunity
to address the subcommittee and also
address any of the objections that have
been submitted
ahead of the committee that have all
been submitted in writing
the subcommittee and other attendees to
the
subcommittee may then ask questions
of uh of that presentation
and then in turn other
objectives or other people attending to
to support the application will also be
given a similar opportunity
to make their representations and again
there will be an opportunity to ask
those parties um questions
on their representations uh at the end
the
the applicant will have the final say to
sum up their application
and the subcommittee will then uh retire
with myself um to deliberate
their decision and then we will come
back to the the open
subcommittee to uh announce what that
decision is
so item two of the agenda actually says
election of a chairman but as councillor
martin newman
is the chairman of the full licensing
and regulatory committee
uh he automatically chairs this
subcommittee so uh
councillor newman i now hand over to you
okay thank you very much um
apologies for absence that'll be uh the
covenant's officer karen please
no apologies received chair uh any
declarations of interest
none from cancer carbondale
um i'd like to introduce ourselves i'm
mark newman and i'm chairman
and i'd like to go down the list of
everyone can uh introduce yourself
and i'm councillor stewart carpendale
ward member for cable st mary
and i'm councillor peter beer member of
the great cornard
and the officers please
um as already mentioned i'm nigel to
learn the legal advisor to the
subcommittee
[Music]
hey bid david price licensing officer
and karen would you like to introduce
yourself karen sayer governance officer
and catherine
um catherine's not joining us i don't
think but um i'm here i'm emma richbell
i'm the assistant manager food safety
and licensing
all right lovely thank you
could the applicants introduce yourself
please
hello i'm charlotte david mills
applicant i'm also here with my husband
craig mills okay
have you got sorry do you want to speak
mr mills i i need to introduce myself
yeah so craig mills fellow director
gold quest um fellow applicant
okay um can you confirm the receipt of
uh
of all the relevant paperwork yes i can
confirm receipt
right uh the uh other persons in the
meeting would you like to introduce
yourself
uh yes hello my name is alexia walker
i'm a resident
and a supporter of the application
um i'm known as sasha okay thank you i
think we've got
someone else is it graham
we've got some other people want to
introduce yourself
yep hi my name is simon hewitt um i'm a
nearby resident of the site um i
lodged an objection but i have
subsequently seen
what i think is a new document appendix
d so i'll be modifying
my position when uh given the
opportunity to speak
okay so is there anyone else
here no was that gwen was her grain
i don't think she's joined the meeting
chair okay that's all i wanted to know
right um
uh does any parties of the hearings wish
to withdraw either their
application or their representation
i won't be withdrawing my application no
that's great it's all right
question to the licensing office have
there been any requests from parties for
permission to call witnesses yeah you
need to go to the other
other persons before skipping on coming
to me
so you need to go to sasha and simon
first
sorry uh
sasha and simon do you wish to speak
later
uh yes i i just simon hewitt here yeah
i'd like to
just uh say a few words yes okay
and sasha would you like to speak thank
you chairman yes i would like to speak
to you
okay thank you chair i think we just
need to clarify whether
any of those parties um wish to withdraw
um any of their representations okay
sorry about that would you um uh sasha
would you like to draw any of your
representations
no i wouldn't would you
uh no but as i said i would like to
modify my position but
um some of it remains thank you
thank you very much right question to
the license officer
have there been any requests for the
parties for permission to call witnesses
no chair okay have the parties
indicated they wish to present documents
none was steve chair okay
uh what applicant mr mrs mills what sort
of time do you estimate you'd like to
speak
for um i don't think it'd be longer than
five minutes
that's great uh the other people
sasha how long do you think you would
want to speak for
hello um just hopefully three or four
minutes all right
and simon the same uh yeah likewise
thank you
okay thank you
right we'll move to the hearing would
the license officer like to present the
case please
uh chair i will summarize the report and
the matter in hand
um i won't um go through the report
verbatim i
shall jump around so you have to bear
with me
this hearing is to determine an
application made for the grant of a new
premises license
made under section 17 of the licensing
act 2003
for gold crest agriculture and property
limited
in relation to the premises of shotley
vineyard frog valley shortly
in ipswich the application was sued by
the licensing authority on the 17th of
april 2020
and a copy of this is attached to this
report as appendix a
the application was has been subject to
the statutory consultation period
as prescribed by regulation the notices
advertising the application
have been on display at the premises and
published in east england daily times
the 20th of april 2020 edition
the information provided with the
application outlines
that the sale and supply of alcohol for
consumption both on and off the premises
late night refreshment indoors films
indoors and outdoors
recording music indoors and outdoors and
live music indoors and outdoors is
proposed as part of a vineyard
with online sales tastings tours food
and wine pairing events and weddings
full details of the pros activities and
timings and the steps proposed in the
operating schedule
are contained within the application
form the taxes appendix a to this report
the operating schedule steps proposed by
the applicant to promote the licensing
objectives
are listed at part m of the application
form
a hearing is necessary to determine the
application for the receipt of
representations which have not been
withdrawn
the subcommittee will be aware that its
consideration is confined to promoting
the four licensing objectives
and a need or commercial demand for
licensed premises
are not a consideration for licensing
anxiety when discharging its
functions as outlined by the secretary
of state
at paraguay 14.19 of the guidance issued
under section 102 of the licensing act
in carrying out its functions the
licensing authority must have regard
to its statement and licensing policy
published under section 5
of the act and any guidance issued by
the secular state under section 182
the licensing authority must carry out
its functions under the act
with a review with a view to promoting
the licensing objectives which
are the prevention of crime and disorder
public safety the prevention of public
nuisance and the protection of children
from harm
where revisions are made to the
legislation or guidance issued by the
secretary of state
there may be a period of time when the
local statement of licensing policy is
inconsistent with these revisions
in these circumstances the licensing
society will have regard
and give appropriate weight to the
relevant changes
guidance and its own statement licensing
policy
the subcommittee will be aware of human
rights act
1998 considerations specifically article
6 for the applicant
and articles 8 and 1 of protocol 1
for those raising representations when
determining applications for the grant
of a new licence
members of the subcommittee will be
aware that lysing act is not the primary
mechanism for the general control of
nuisance and anti-social behaviour by
individuals
once they are away from the licensed
premises and therefore beyond direct
control over the individual
club or business holding the license
certification or authorization concerned
nonetheless the licensing act 2003
contributes towards
a holistic approach to the management of
the evening and nighttime economy
as outlined by the secretary of state at
paragraph 14.3 of the guidance issued
under section 182 and
they would history council statement
licensing policy at 1.9
members of the subcommittee will be
aware of their statutory guidance
at 14.64 and 14.65 which states that
licensing and planning are different
regimes
and neither is bound by the others
decisions
there are circumstances when a condition
of planning permission
at terminal hour has been set for the
use of the premises for commercial
purposes
where these hours are different to the
lasting hours the applicant must observe
the earlier closing time
premises operating in breach of the
planning permission would be liable for
prosecution and the planning law public
nuisance is given its strategy meaning
in many pieces of legislation however
under the lysing act
it is not narrowly defined and retains
its broad common law meaning
as outlined by the secular state and its
guidance at two point one six
the last thing at license authority
general approach to considerating
licensing hours is contained within
section
six of the local statement lighting
policy
and section seven guides on relevant
representations
the licensing authority has received no
representations from
any of the responsible authorities under
the act
however environmental health as a
responsible authority under the act
have undertaken mediation on their areas
of concern
and the outcome of their mediation is
attached as appendix due to this report
there have been nine representations in
total
received by other persons and these are
taxed as appendix b to this report
the subcommittee having regard to the
representations made
may take such the steps if any are
considered appropriate for the promotion
and licensing objectives
these are to grant the license subject
to conditions which are consistent with
the operating schedule
accompanying the application modify to
such an extent
as the authority considers appropriate
for operation and licensing objectives
and subject to any mandatory conditions
which must also be included in license
or to exclude from the scope of the
license any license activities through
which the application relates
or to refuse to specify a person in the
license as
the premises supervisor or lastly to
reject the application
for these purposes conditions on the
license are modified
if any of them are altered or omitted or
any new condition is added
any party agreed by the decision of the
licensing authority in respect of this
application has a statutory variety of
appeal to the magistrates court
and that concludes the officer summary
okay thank you very much um i'll give
you the opportunity to ask questions uh
mr and mrs mills do you have any
questions of the license officer
no i don't have any questions um sasha
walker do you have any questions for the
license officer
no questions yeah um simon do you have
any questions
no thanks right um peter do you have any
peter beer
uh no no no uh sir cartel do you have
any questions
no questions thing okay
well could the applicant um put their
case then please
mr mrs mills okay
um i've just prepared a short statement
just to hopefully give you a little bit
of um
a feel for the business and our journey
so far um
we took over the vineyard in 2017 and
began regenerating the site
which hadn't been intended for some
years this is a long-term project
and we're invested in the area we've
been we've lived in shortly for over 30
years and have owned valentine cottage
next to the church and the vineyard
since 2011.
as a family we're very much embedded in
the local community
as with most agriculture the vineyard
requires
a degree of diversification in order to
be sustainable
it's important that we have a premises
license in order to
ensure the sustainability of the
vineyard adverse weather conditions
would have a huge impact on the vines so
it's important for us to have another
dimension to the business our main
priority is
will be the vines which is evident by us
recently agreeing to a 15-year lease on
a larger plot of land
we wish to diversify to mitigate and
manage those bad years
just as our arable farming neighbors
would
we were granted planning permission in
october 2018
which permitted us to host glampers and
allowed us to build a barn
the barn would have a wine tasting area
facilities for glampers and a storage
area for vineyard equipment and
machinery
an application for a premises license is
the next step for our business
it's crucial to our business that we
obtain a premises license so we can
trade
and move into the next phase of our
business our wine currently resides in a
winery unable to be sold
although this application has received
representations we have support from
neighbours and the wider community
numerous people comment on how we are
improving the area and doing something
which will encourage investment
and directly benefit other local
businesses we have a local business
advertising the vineyard
on their holiday rental website
upon review of the representations it
appears the main concerns relate to
prevention of public
nuisance and public safety this is on
the basis of noise disturbance and
behavior once alcohol has been consumed
i have been working closely with baber
and the environment protection
team on part m of the application this
considers all of the licensing
objectives and how the business can be
run in accordance with these
there is already a management plan in
place which was a requirement of our
planning permission i've read through
the
representations and note that a lot of
the concerns
are the same as we received when we were
going through our planning application
i'd like to say to our neighbours who
have raised concerns especially around
noise
that we are already limited in our
planning with events where noise levels
may be raised
and we have been in contact with the
environment protection team
the agreement we have reached with the
environment protection team will
reassure
neighbours whilst also allowing us to
run events complementary to the vineyard
we wish to virtually build the business
while maintaining a close relationship
with baber district council and other
relevant authorities
we have purposely restricted ourselves
in respect of the weddings and glamping
and have documented a comprehensive
management plan to ensure
no or little disruption growing grapes
is our main priority and always will be
i can't stress enough our love and our
passion for the surrounding area
and how committed we are to ensure a
minimum amount of disruption for
neighbours
members of the public and our own family
as we are also neighbours to the
vineyard thank you thank you
okay abby thank you right um uh
peter beard do you have any questions
does that caught me off guard um not
really
um just just can um the applicant
clarify that's really to remind me uh
they
they live sort of on the premises right
beside it or something don't they can
could you just confirm whether that's
still the case
yes we are in close proximity to the
vineyard
thank you okay um sue sue carpenter
would you like to ask any questions
if i may please yes um i do have several
some of which are for clarification some
i suppose might be just curiosity if if
i may
um you've told us that you took over the
vineyard in 2017.
i'm curious to know where you actually
make the wine where you bottle it
and where it's stored uh so
um the the greats actually at the moment
go to a winery in sussex
right and they they could go to all
manner of places um
last year i would say was our first
proper harvest because we've got around
22 tons of the site
the year previous to that we didn't get
as much because we were still
regenerating the site so we didn't
expect such a large harvest
um but they could go all over the
country to different wineries we do have
someone interested
in london as well but we don't have a
winery on site
right so it's not when it is bottled
it's not
not on on site either it's not stored on
site
some in the future may be sold on site
because if we do get our license
i would have to have some stock on site
in order to do tastings
indeed yes um can i query what you mean
in your application by
um where you have to indicate indoors or
outdoors
indoors apart from the barn for your
tasting area what other structures
constitute
indoors
tasting areas yeah i believe it's to be
the barn unless
if someone erected a marquee that would
be also considered indoors
yes i i wondered if that might be the
case because i was thinking about
the um possible use of of live or
recorded music and whether
it would be in in the barn or in the
marquee so
it could be in in both i suppose uh and
i wondered where on the site you might
consider for
staging for live or recorded music
they be in the barn yes and in the
marquee
so if there's a wedding okay
okay fine thank you bye um
i was looking at your response to sex
and j
on page 25 of the application
find that page again myself
i found that a little confusing
uh what do you actually mean in that
that section
um is the wine to be sold online stored
on site i suspect
not unless it's for immediate
consumption
no the white the wine will be stored on
site um so fulfillment will be
from from the actual vineyard itself
when you're handling the orders that's
right yeah so fulfillment at the moment
will be from the bar
um if capacity rises then we'll look at
specific fulfillment
and companies that can hopefully uh
deliver our
uh wines across the gb um that's the
intention
yes so you'd be hoping for a national
market
that's correct yeah yes okay um
so will you be serving food um like
breakfast from the tasting area of the
new barn
uh no there's not plans actually uh to
serve food from there
as yet okay all right thank you
um and how many bar areas page
35 it might simply be the barn
itself and the um and the marquee
that's correct yes that that is correct
yeah lovely thank you very much for
answering her questions
it's just going back to food because
breakfast is not included
but that food will be served from the
site if we did a barbecue or we did a
tasting
there would be lunch and supper clubs
right i think you implied that
your glampers might um might come in for
breakfast
or did i misread that and yes so at the
moment we don't have
kitchen facilities so if they did it
would be um a continental style
breakfast
oh i see right okay thank you
good thank you for the license
could i come back mr chairman yes girl
thank you it was just something that sue
highlighted
um but to the uh applicant um
i'm right in uh trying to remember
saying from the pictures on page 41
that the clampers and uh marquees and
that will be further down
the bottom the furthest part away from
the hoses is that correct uh
not necessarily the glampers will be
absolutely
right the marquee for any wedding will
be at the top
of the site nearer the church end that's
correct
sorry that's that's correct thank you
that's answered my part okay
what would the license officer david
have any questions
uh i don't care no okay um
sasha walker would you have any
questions
no questions no i was going to ask two
where she goes to get one for breakfast
but that's been clarified thank you
simon do you have any uh not a present
no thanks
okay um sasha would you like to make
your statement then please
yes uh i would um i'd start by saying
a full-time president here right in the
middle
of the vineyard um the applicant
may it's a huge commitment that they
have to this and a huge commitment to
the area
um i'm able to observe actually how much
work
goes into the vineyard
and how much it's going to need to be
sustainable
how much the vintage could bring to the
community
how much it could bring in terms of jobs
which i know that we're all quite
keen on future financially
um and i think that this is
a big trust exercise on both sides i
would say the vineyard owners have been
incredibly considerate of the neighbours
each element of planning which although
i only moved in in august i was very
aware of
because i was considering moving in they
sought to relay everybody's fears
they're very approachable
they're around all the time because they
live here um
and you can go and ask them why is this
here
what's this point and if one can trust
him to answer
those questions and i think one can ask
them
to get on with it efficiently and
properly
one of the things that i put in my
representation was
that the area of outstanding natural
beauty and the
integrity of the area is what's going to
make
this business so attractive and i don't
think the applicants are going to be
doing anything to jeopardize that
um i would also like to go through a few
points that have been raised in some of
the other representations
uh things like traffic and people
driving in who don't know where they're
going
um we already have a church on the site
which uh holds weddings
and holds funerals and as locals we have
to be aware that there are people
driving to western funerals who don't
know where they're going
um and in fact the only people to be
affected by extra traffic
that isn't currently coming to the
church would be those coming down the
track and i live down the track
we will know that it's coming we will be
able to plan for it
um the owners are very open about
everything that's going on
and we're always able to plan for things
and they've been building if they've had
any construction
vehicles coming they've let us know in
advance so that we can get cars out
and get our own delivery in there's been
no problem
with any of that um and as for live
music i think this is one of the things
that can really
it's damage limitation you have to look
at what they're trying to do
if you've got sweating and you've booked
a string quartet
to play the bride of the aisle something
happens and those guys can't turn up
are you going to leave the bride with no
music or are you going to put some live
music on and save the day
um people spend a lot of money
on their weddings and they have a
certain level of
requirement and expectation and it's not
going to suit business if they can't
fulfill that expectation and they need
to be
sustainable they need to be able to
diversify they have planning permission
for weddings they have conditions in
place
in planning permission they are well
aware of the
the planning commission is the top
consideration
um as the licensing officer mentioned
that trumps everything
so in applying for a license
understanding
is that they need to try and cover every
eventuality
and that sometimes that means that the
licensing looks like more than they have
planning for
but planning will await trump
and i know that they will adhere to that
um i don't think that there could be any
particular nuisance i think we can all
plan for it
i trust the owners um i think that's
really all that i have to say i'm very
enthusiastic about this i live in the
middle of it i've got lots of points
here but
i don't think they need matching i think
they're booking this business
the license is an absolute no-brainer
there is no point in making this wine if
they can't sell it
um and live next door to former winery
where there was a pond in the garden
next door
where the wine was made it was bottled
it was stored
so they were precedent we've also got
president from the wrenches barns for
weddings uh people at number five have a
wedding at the wrench's barns
so we all know how it works um and i
think she just
go ahead thank you okay
thank you very much sir um simon would
you like to
do your statement please
uh yeah thanks um by way of introduction
i'm a residence
um live close to the church so i'm about
70 meters from the boundary of the site
um first thing i'd like to say is that
i'm very supportive of what craig and
charlotte are doing i think they're
doing a fantastic job
um i want to see this be a huge success
i'm looking forward to enjoying the
facilities myself
so my starting position is that i would
very much
like them to have a license i
quite completely agree with what
charlotte said that
it's as a business it needs to have
diversification
um clearly a lot of entertainment
requires an alcohol license so
i'm very much in favor of a license
being issued for the site it's simply a
question of the conditions that are
imposed upon it
we've heard a lot about trust i would
like to
say that as close neighbors to
craig and charlotte i completely trust
what they say they've made a large
number of
um commitments and reassurances both
in writing and verbally and i completely
trust that
but we do have to remember that this
license is being
issued to goldcrest it's a company it's
a corporate entity
which can be sold at any time now
i sincerely hope that that will never
happen that craig and charlotte will
continue to run this business
um long after i'm dead and buried but
it is a company they could sell it at
any time
and so the trust that we have in them as
individuals
um is not particularly relevant because
any day the the the company could be
sold and can be running
could be run by somebody else who is not
invested in the local community and so
on
so i think we need to remember that so
it's not a personal thing at all
i completely trust what they say but the
reality is
um craig and charlotte uh gold crest
rather
are the the fourth owners of the
vineyard in a period of less than 15
years
um it's a precarious business i'm very
confident that they're going about it in
a much more um business-like
way than their predecessors have done
because of this diversification but
nevertheless
business is always precarious the
company could be sold at any time
so we're not talking about the trust we
have in craig and charlotte at all
what we're talking about is a license
that
accrues the gold crest which could be
sold
at any time so that's a really important
point
you'll have seen from my written
objection which i don't propose to go
through in detail
that the key things that i'm concerned
about
are the sale of alcohol sale
and consumption of alcohol on the
premises 24 hours a day this is not just
wine that's produced this could be any
alcohol obviously
and again reassurances um
are great but any new owner of gold
crest might
would not be bound by informal
reassurances
so the idea of selling alcohol 24 hours
a day
in this fairly remote rural setting
which is a very quiet location
um simply does not seem to be
appropriate
in terms of your requirement
to prevent public nuisance i think as we
all know
the consumption of alcohol can often
lead to public nuisance
even in a busy environment in a quite
rural environment
it could very easily do so even if it is
just about
uh slightly raucous behavior late at
night
whatever it may be i'm not necessarily
talking about criminal behavior
uh anti-social behavior simply
uh high-spirited uh boisterous behavior
which is often
associated with events where alcohol is
served
so 24-hour alcohol sales i think
is is is highly inappropriate um
the appendix d
that went around with the documentation
i had not seen that
at the time my objection was
was put in i think it was it hadn't been
published by that
by that time um it's it's a it's a
useful document and it's an interesting
document
but i think we've just heard that the
definition of
indoors includes a marquee marquee would
i think normally be at the top of the
field quite close to
the church and from a selfish point of
view close to my house and
and other houses um so i'm afraid the
idea
that alcohol could be served at a party
in a marquee 24 hours a day
in a quite rural area strikes me as
being
um inappropriate
so i am more than happy
for a license to be issued for alcohol
consumption both indoors
and outdoors but i do not think
it's appropriate to do that to allow
that 24 hours a day
i think the licensing authority i think
yourselves
should consider what would be a
normal and acceptable thing in a quite
rural area
um i think that in a marquee
um obviously in terms of raucous
behavior and such like
um you may as well be outdoors because
there's no
no noise suppression there so i think
you should seriously
consider imposing a time limit on the
serving of alcohol
which i think could reasonably be 10 30
or or 11 o'clock
probably in the evening probably earlier
on a sunday
sorry chair we've gone past five minutes
sorry to interrupt
can you can you sign up then please
simon uh to finish
very briefly so that's the key point
similarly um uh recorded me uh amplified
music
within a marquee i think will would
cause
public nuisance almost inevitably
um i would say that the
the license should be issued but there
should be uh stringent
uh appropriate time controls on both
those two activities
to ensure that public nuisance is is
prevented
um on that basis i'd be more than happy
to withdraw my objection but i think 24
hour alcohol sales
and amplified music outdoors until 11 30
at night
is not appropriate in this setting thank
you thank you simon
okay um peter beer do you have any
questions
for sasha to start with uh
right um no
i've got a question i think for simon
yeah well i'm gonna ask you that next
do you have any questions for simon yeah
i did have one for sasha but i've
forgotten it now
so it couldn't have been that important
but um simon
you say you live near the church um
and these marquees if my memory services
are correct are going to be
uh the top end of the field but looking
from the bottom
up towards the church that's to the left
i think if i'm right
from memory and then there's a church
yard and then there's a road
and then the church is on the other side
and then you're across the road i assume
in one of those houses
along there is that correct so i can
just get an idea of where baits you are
um it's uh i'm not quite sure what you
have in mind
um the the top of the field i mean it's
quite a narrow field the top of the
fields
is where the marquee would be um and
between my house and that marquee
is effectively just the church yard the
graveyard
of the church so it's it's 70 my house
is 70 meters from the boundary of the
site with nothing intervening other than
trees and in the churchyard yeah
and the church that is where i've um
finished it thank you very much
okay um sue carlton do you have any
questions for sasha
uh no i don't have any for simon uh
no i don't except just looking at um
google maps here you you'd be sort of
between the war memorial
and old hall road is that right simon
uh no uh that's that's not correct
um if you look at uh google maps sorry
i'm just going to try and get it up
so i can talk you through it but we
we are um a house by itself
um on the other side of the church from
the
applicant's site i see okay got it oh
um we are sorry i'm just looking at that
myself now just
so don't mislead you we are directly
north of the uh where the
the marquee the field the north slight
slightly
slightly northwest yeah you're on the
google earth you'll see
the church building and then to the to
the north of that you'll see a
detached house standing by itself that
is our house which
as i say there's there are trees in the
churchyard
but other than that uh it's it's open
land between ourselves and the marquee
yeah i see it thank you simon thank you
thank you well um last season officer uh
david do you have any questions for
sasha
no chair uh any for simon no chair
no okay then i'll move on to closing
submission
um yeah you have to ask the applicant
whether he has any questions for either
the
other persons all right thank you uh mr
mrs mills do you have any questions
for uh sasha no question no
any for simon no questions okay thank
you very much
very good i'll move on to the closing
submission so the license officer can
give a closing statement please
yeah i just summarized the um
the basis of your considerations are
kept to the forward licensing objectives
and the recommendations which are
part of the lysine act 2003.
thank you with mr mrs mills like to give
a closing statement
i think all we just like to add in terms
of the 24 hours that was there to
accommodate
late night refreshments for our glampers
and our online our online sales
um and and we're under the impression
that
refreshments doesn't actually mean
alcohol so um
if there's if there's conditions that
allow us to sell alcohol online 24 hours
and
provide those um conditions for our
glampers
and to serve cups of teas and coffees
yes um
then yes we would be um accommodating to
that and that's what we'd like to add i
think
charlotte okay thank you all very much
may i just come back on that on that
point chairman if i may
who's that this is simon hewitt um
i think there may be a misunderstanding
here because um
section i in the license is late night
refreshment
which is cups of tea and coffee whatever
24 hours a day indoors i'm perfectly
happy with that that's not the objection
the alcohol is separate that's section j
it's the alcohol license late 24 hours
which is the concern of many residents
it's not serving cups of tea to glampers
at
midnight if it's a chilly night or
whatever that's absolutely fine
okay thank you for that right i'll move
on to
exclusion of the public so i've got a
little bit to read out
on the basis that the subcommittee
considers that
the public interest in excluding the
public out of
outweighs the public interest
in its deliberation being held in the
public it is
resolved that under section 100a stroke
4
of the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for item 13
on the grounds that involves a likely
disclosure of exempt
information as defined in part one of
schedule 12
of the act on the ground set in
regulation 14 stroke 2 of the licensing
act 2003
hearing registration 205 so
i now go into private session i i will
second that chairman
thank you so we'll move and um
i think mr mr wills and sasha and this
time have gotten
moved to another meeting have they or
will you move to another meeting
so yourself um the committee members and
the legal officer
you now need to leave this meeting and
join your private session to deliberate
and everybody else can either wait here
or we'll set a time for everybody to
come back
um should we say half an hour but of
course you may not may not be
back yourselves by then and then we'll
just wait for you
can i just be clear uh karen um
just explain we've got to come out of
this meeting and then i've got to join
the license and here and deliberation in
private is that that's the one yep join
that one and then
and then everybody else can either wait
here
or um go away and come back in half an
hour
and you may or may not be back in half
an hour but we'll wait for you is that
all right
thank you okay thank you we'll leave
this meeting then
thank you
last 15 minutes past so we can go ahead
now would you like to give the decision
then please
for me certainly um
thank you for everyone's patience the
the subcommittee have uh carefully
considered this application
um and that they are satisfied that some
with the conditions
in the operating schedule together with
the conditions
uh included an appendix d together with
one additional condition which they
would like to impose
um and the additional condition is that
there should be no sales of alcohol for
consumption
on the premises before 10 a.m each
morning
the reason for that additional condition
is to
avoid any confusion as there is the
24-hour condition
uh permission to sell
and to facilitate the the online sales
but the members felt that that
additional condition was required just
to remove any uncertainty
from when uh the sound of alcohol ends
um
the previous night um as in accordance
with one of the new conditions
and then again 10 o'clock the following
morning so therefore the
uh the application is granted subjects
to those conditions
um there is a right of appeal to
any person who made the application or
made a representation to
the uh the subcommittee on this
application to appeal
to the magistrates court within 21 days
of the date of receiving notification of
this
decision thank you okay lovely
thank you nigel well that is the end of
this meeting thank you all for
participating
and we'll meet again meeting close
[Music]
you